Stephanie pomboy is an economist CEO of
macro Maven she joins us tonight to
assess Stephanie thanks so much for
coming on so as always the beneficiaries
of these schemes are never the people
who they tell you they are oh the
oppressed the Hopeless in our inner city
there's always their donors who are
buying up residential homes and turning
them into rental properties I mean
that's who's winning here Democratic
donors
gee you think
um you know I'm reminded of that old
expression
um those who refuse to learn from
history are doomed to repeat it we tried
this exercise under George Bush when
they decided that we needed to create a
home ownership society and uh you know
the Bush Administration in conjunction
with Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac you'll
recall Franklin Reigns and Barney Frank
all got in and decided that we needed to
make it easier for people to become
homeowners and we all remember how well
that whole situation worked out but I
would argue this situation is even more
Sinister than what you outlined in terms
of trying to get people to move to the
suburbs and uh you know basically
control them into Home Ownership because
we are on the doorstep of a another
deflating home bubble right now so
essentially what they're doing is
they're encouraging people to stretch
into home songs that they couldn't
otherwise afford precisely as the floor
is about to fall out underneath them as
prices decline and we got existing homes
sales as reported by the National
Association of Realtors yesterday and it
reflects the second back-to-back month
of declining home prices so it's here
already and we have seen sales volumes
just collapse at a speed that is even
faster than we saw during the housing
bubble bust and that presages an equally
substantial decline on prices so I think
we will again for only the second time
in our history see Nationwide home
prices decline so this idea that now is
the time to encourage people who can't
otherwise afford to get into homes to do
so is really really dangerous these
people will probably be underwater in
their homes before they even get the
keys then what then what kind of policy
are they going to prescribe you know I
shudder to a imagine and you know it
goes without saying Tucker or it should
that the reason homes are increasingly
unaffordable for people is because we
have spent over a decade pushing money
into this economy with Reckless monetary
and fiscal policy that inflated a
massive bubble in housing that now the
FED is raising rates to dampen so you
have a combination of inflated home
prices and higher interest rates that
have made it unaffordable it's not
racism that's making homes unaffordable
it's Reckless policy and they're
layering more Reckless policy on top to
solve it so nicely put so nicely put
this is what asset inflation looks like
for the average person Stephanie Palm
boy I appreciate your coming on tonight
thank you subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight